oh oh the call has
started looks like we've got some
movement in the burough some movement in
the burrow folks that means we are
getting near to ballzack Billy now just
a reminder if he sees his shadow
oh gosh he's looking good this year
isn't he he's going back oh well oh
maybe maybe make it his mind okay there
we go oh yeah he's he's got some debris
on him but that's to be expected after
you've been spent the winter in
hibernation oh do the stretch Billy do
the stretch taking a look around this is
the moment of Oh I thought he was going
to anyhow just some squats oh some
calistenics to start that
that's oh wait looking
looking looking
looking
oh he sees his shadow which means six
more months of
winter that is disappointing but we
can't blame
Billy keep your snow brush handy is what
Billy is telling us keep that snow brush
handy the